ADAM MARTIN: So I
guess I will start by,
first of all,
congratulating you all.
Since the last
time I've seen you,
you've all regenerated
your intestine.
So it's like you're
a brand new person.
So there's that.
I want to start the lecture
by talking about something
I've been putting off
telling you about,
which is the Nobel Prize
in physiology or medicine
that was awarded this year.
And it was awarded to James
Allison and Tasuku Honjo
for their discovery of a way
to harness the immune system
to fight cancer.
And we're going to talk
about the immune system
later in the course,
and it turns out,
I will lecture on it.
And I've actually
had immunology,
and in fact, I had immunology
with James Allison.
So I will do my best to
channel James Allison when
I talk about the immune system.
But what they won
the prize for is,
they figured out a way
to essentially release
the brake on the
immune system in order
to allow the immune system
to better fight cancer.
And this is a technique that's
been used in the clinic,
and there are currently a
number of clinical trials
that are also looking
to see whether this
can be used in a variety
of different cancer types.
OK.
So I just wanted to
point that out now
because we're
talking about cancer,
and I'll go more
into the mechanism
as how this works
when we start talking
about the immune system.
So as I mentioned
in the last lecture,
cancer is basically
a progressive loss
of tissue organization.
And luckily for us,
our body has a number
of different barriers to cells
becoming cancerous and forming
a tumor.
And so I wanted
to start out just
by having you guys tell me what
you feel the barriers would
be to this process.
So who has an idea of a barrier?
What are the barriers
in place by your body
to prevent cancer cells from
arising and forming a tumor,
and for this process to
form a malignant tumor?
What's that?
Oh, Rachel, sorry.
STUDENT: Apoptosis.
ADAM MARTIN: Apoptosis
is a good one, right.
So there's a careful
process in your body
to limit how long certain
cells are resident in the body.
And all of this depends
on communication
between different cell
types in your body--
so barriers to tumor agenesis.
And one type of signal
is a survival signal.
And if a cell is not
getting a survival signal,
then the cell will
undergo apoptosis,
which is what Rachel
was referring to.
So one barrier is that
there is a highly regulated
system of determining
whether or not cells divide
and also whether
or not cells live.
OK.
So there are growth
survival signals,
which means that the decision
for a cell to go off its rocker
and just start
dividing uncontrollably
is not likely for a normal cell.
Something has to happen to that
cell in order to perturb it.
So what are some other
barriers to forming a tumor
and for that tumor
to become invasive?
Yes, Jeremy?
STUDENT: You just mentioned
it, but the immune system.
ADAM MARTIN: Yeah.
So this cancer cell can't
activate the immune system.
So you could have some
type of immunosuppression
of the cancer.
And I won't talk
about that today,
but maybe we'll come back
and talk about it when we
talk about the immune system.
OK.
Looking at this diagram,
when the tumor proceeds
to invasive cancer,
what do you think
are some barriers to
that process happening?
What are cells normally
doing in an organ?
The cells that line
your intestine,
are they invading into
the surrounding tissue?
No.
Jeremy is shaking
his head no, right?
So normally, cells don't do
that, or certain types of cells
do, but normally,
if you have cells
that are the lining
of an epithelium,
they're not going off
to a blood vessel.
OK.
So I'm just going to review
the structure of the tissue,
and then we'll talk about
some of the barriers that
prevent this from happening.
So I'm drawing a
tubular organ here.
This could be the
tube of the intestine.
There'd be a lumen inside here.
It could be some ductal
structure in an organ,
like a mammary gland.
It could be that this
is the airway of a lung,
and there's an epithelial
lining around that airway.
So these cells here are
forming an epithelial lining.
And one important aspect
of epithelial biology
is, immature epithelia,
they have a floor
that the cells stand on.
So this structure that I
just drew around these cells
in green is known as
the basement membrane.
It's the basement because it's
the floor that this other thing
is built on.
And this basement
membrane is made out
of what is known as the
extracellular matrix, which
I'll just call matrix right now,
and the extracellular matrix
are basically
extracellular proteins
that form a mesh work that
forms a rigid structure on which
epithelial cells can sit on.
OK, now if we think about
what surrounds this organ,
there's also matrix proteins
in the intervening areas.
And this is known as
connective tissue.
And so if we think
about the cells that
are the epithelial cells
here, they are in one state,
and this state is known as
epithelial, as I just said.
So these are epithelial cells.
Epithelial cells
have a few properties
that are really distinguishing.
The first is that they have
high intercellular adhesion.
And the next is
that, if you consider
their relative mobility,
they can obviously
move within the epithelium
because we talked
about the intestine
and how cells
are moving from the base of
the crypts up to the villus.
But in general, these cells
aren't moving in and out
of the organ.
So I would say that they have
a low migratory potential.
And so these are the
epithelial cells that are here.
Now there are also cells that
are in this interstitial space,
and I'll draw-- they often
have this highly elongated
morphology.
And these cells are in a
fundamentally different state.
And this state is known
as mesenchymal or stromal.
So this area outside the organ
is also known as the stroma.
So they're known as stromal
cells in this location.
And these cells have
very different properties
than the epithelial cells in
that they have low adhesion--
I should say low
cell-to-cell adhesion.
And in contrast to
these epithelial cells,
these stromal cells, as you
see in this example up here--
that's a human neutrophil--
these stromal cells
are highly migratory.
So that neutrophil is
chasing a bacterium,
and they'll eventually get
it, but the movie will loop,
and so you'll see it constantly
chasing that bacterium.
So some examples
of stromal cells
would be immune cells,
like this human neutrophil.
And you probably know
that immune cells
have to traverse
different organ systems.
They have to be rapidly
recruited to sites of infection
or sites of injury.
And so this type of
cell is fundamentally
different from the types of
cells that line your organs,
where you basically need
those cells to stay put.
When considering cancer, you
have these different types
of cells in your body.
90% of cancer comes from a
cell of epithelial origin.
So 90% of cancers are
epithelial in origin.
Some other examples
of stromal cells
are cells like fibroblasts.
And fibroblasts are cells
that secrete and remodel
the matrix that's in
connective tissue.
And they're also important for
wound healing and secreting
matrix during the
wound-healing process.
So that's just to give
you a few examples.
OK.
So now let's come back to this
example and talk about what
happens to get a cell to
go all the way from being
a normal epithelial cell to
having this type of behavior,
where initially you
have growth and a loss
of the control over growth
and survival signaling,
and eventually, the
cancer can become
what's known as malignant?
So it's a progression, and
initially, you might just
get increased in-cell division
and abnormal cell shape, which
is known as dysplasia,
and at that point,
it's known as something like
an adenoma or something that's
benign.
But it's this last
point here, up here,
where the cells breach
this basement membrane.
When that happens, then the
cancer is known as carcinoma,
and it's malignant.
So malignant cancer is cancer
that has breached the basement
membrane.
So I want to take you through
the progression of tumor
genesis.
And first, I'm going to
start with the breakdown
of this growth
survival signaling.
And I just wanted to
remind you about what
we talked about with the
intestine as our model organ.
And in the intestine,
remember that this is all
regulated by signals between
stem cells and niche cells.
So the niche cells are
sending the stem cells
signals like Wnts that
control their self renewal,
and then it's the loss
of this signaling that
allows these cells to eventually
undergo apoptosis and get
shed into the lumen
of the intestine.
So one of the first
steps in cancer
is this breakdown in
growth survival signaling.
So this first breakdown is going
to enable the cells to overcome
this first barrier.
And so as I just
pointed out, remember,
it helps to think of
what has to happen
in a normal tissue or organ.
Normally, the decision whether
or not a cell divides or dies--
so cell division
and also death--
is highly regulated.
And it's regulated by
communication with other cells.
So in cancer, this
regulation goes awry.
And how would this
regulation go awry?
Yeah, Jeremy?
STUDENT: Loss of function
in a tumor suppressor
or an over-activation
of the oncogene.
ADAM MARTIN: Mm-hmm.
So Jeremy suggested that
there could be mutations,
like oncogenic mutations
or tumor suppressor
loss, that lead to abnormal
cell division and death.
And that is exactly right.
So you could have
oncogenic mutations,
and these oncogenic mutations,
they often hyperactivate
or constitutively activate these
growth-signaling pathways that
are normally downstream of
growth factors and receptor
tyrosine kinases.
And if you
hyperactivate those, you
reduce the dependency of
the cells on these signals.
So these oncogenic
mutations can reduce
the dependency of cells on
growth factors and growth
signals.
OK.
But one important point is
that this is not enough.
And you can think about this
in the case of the intestine
because if you had an oncogenic
mutation in one of these cells
here, it might not
be as dependent
on signals for growth.
But it doesn't matter
because even though you
had that mutation,
it's going to die,
and it's going to shed
out of the tissue.
And actually what
happens in many cases
where you activate a
signaling pathway that
allows the cell to,
in an abnormal way,
go through the cell
cycle, you actually
induce a failsafe mechanism at
the cell which causes the cell
to undergo apoptosis.
So often, you get
this step happening,
and the cells just
undergo apoptosis
because you've evolved
to protect your organs
from this type of mutation.
So it's the oncogenic
mutation, in collaboration
with loss of tumor suppression,
and one of the main tumor
suppressive mechanisms
our body has is apoptosis,
where if a cell is doing
something abnormal,
the cells simply dies.
So loss of the tumor
suppressor could
be loss of a gene that promotes
apoptosis, and in that case,
if the cell loses
that mechanism,
the cell will avoid apoptosis.
OK.
So this is oncogenic
mutations and the loss
of tumor suppressors
which subverts
the normal communication
between cells which is required
for normal tissue homeostasis.
OK.
Now another example of this
growth and survival signaling
is not one which
involves, necessarily,
a genetic change, but one that
involves changes in expression.
And it also involves
interaction between the tumor
and the surrounding
cells of the body.
So I'm going to tell you
a little bit about tumor
microenvironment.
And this is something
that's important to consider
in cancer because a tumor in
a body, it's not in isolation.
It's surrounded by other cells
in your body and other things
in your body, like
matrix, and so here is
a picture showing you
a tumor, and the tumor
is stained with this membrane
protein which is shown here
in the rust color.
So that's the tumor.
And what's also stained in this
piece of tissue is the DNA.
It's stained in blue.
And so you see the nuclei
of the tumor cells in there.
But you see all these blue
nuclei surrounding the tumor.
And these are stromal cells
that are around the tumor.
And they've actually been
recruited to the tumor
by the cancer cells.
So what I mean by
tumor microenvironment
is just the region
around the tumor.
And so if you have cancer,
and you have a tumor,
the tumor cells can
actually secrete signals
which recruit stromal cells.
So there can be an
interaction where
the tumor sends recruitment
signals that causes
stromal cells to come by.
And what the stromal cells can
do, what they do for the tumor
and why this is
beneficial for the tumor,
is that stromal cells can
secrete growth signals
or survival signals that
promote the growth of the tumor.
So there can be a reciprocal
interaction here where
you get an abnormal
conversation between cancer
cells and the surrounding
stromal cells.
But again, this is
very similar, if you
think about it, to the
way a normal organ works.
You often have these
signals going between cells.
And that is involved in
normal tissue homeostasis.
What's happening here,
though, is abnormal
and that the cancer
cells are constitutively
recruiting these
stromal cells just
to get this growth signal
that they're addicted to.
And because you have
just the presence
of such a loop suggests
that these cancer cells,
even if they have
oncogenic mutations
and have lost tumor
suppressors, they
are not totally independent
of growth signals.
They still, to some extent,
rely on growth signals.
So these oncogenic mutations,
they reduce the dependency
on growth signals,
but this dependency,
the dependency on growth
signals, is not eliminated.
And one experiment that showed
this was an experiment that
was done back in the 1950s where
patients with a type of skin
cancer, basal cell
carcinoma, were taken,
and they had their
tumors excised
from one part of their body.
And then the tumor was
grafted back onto them,
to another part of their body,
distant from the original site
of the tumor.
And this grafting
experiment was done either
with the stromal
cells that surrounded
the tumor or the stromal
cells surrounding the tumor
were removed, and
just the tumor cells
were grafted back onto the body.
OK.
Now this experiment
probably would not
be allowed today, but back in
the '50s, I guess it was legal.
And so the
experimental result is
that if you graft the tumor
cells with the surrounding
stroma, the tumor was able
to establish a second tumor,
or the tumor cells survived
this grafting procedure,
whereas tumor cells that
were taken without the stroma
underwent cell death when they
were put in a new location.
So there's something about this
specialized microenvironment
that the tumor creates for
itself that is enabling
the tumor to grow and survive.
And the model is that it's
because these stromal cells are
secreting growth factors that
these cancer cells are still
dependent on.
So this dependency on
growth signals is important,
clinically, because
some types of cancer,
there is an elevation of
growth factor receptors
that are associated
with the cancer.
And the famous example of that
is, in 30% of breast cancers,
there is a growth factor
receptor, the HER2 receptor,
which is over expressed
in the cancer cells.
So I just drew a receptor
here, and I'm now talking
about the HER2 receptor.
HER2 stands for human epidermal
growth factor, EGF, receptor 2.
So this is a receptor
tyrosine kinase,
which is a transmembrane
protein receptor.
It's expressed on the
surface of the cell.
And so about 30% of
human breast cancers
are HER2 positive, which means
that the cancer cells are over
expressing this receptor
tyrosine kinase.
The fact that you have these
cancer cells over expressing
a growth factor
receptor suggests
that the cancer
requires some type
of growth stimulus in order
for the cancer to be growing.
And the fact that
this was discovered,
that 30% of breast
cancers over express HER2,
has been used by
researchers to develop
a treatment for this type of
cancer, this HER2 positive.
The treatment is
known as Herceptin.
Possibly some of you
have heard of this.
It was developed at Genentech.
And what Herceptin
is, it's an antibody
that was raised against
a human HER2 protein.
OK.
So Herceptin is an antibody.
It recognizes HER2 on the
surface of these cancer cells,
and you can treat patients
with this antibody,
and an antibody binds to
the HER2 positive cells.
And it either blocks
the function of HER2
or recruits immune cells
to kill those cells off.
The exact mechanism, I
don't believe, is known.
But what is known is
that Herceptin has really
changed how we're able to treat
HER2 positive breast cancers.
And it's been a
huge success story
in the fight against cancer.
All right.
So we've talked about this first
barrier, the barrier to tumor
cells becoming at
least semi-independent
of these growth factors.
And so now I want to
talk about other barriers
to tumor genesis.
And if you consider an
epithelial cell here,
even if these cells
are able to grow,
they won't be able
to leave the organ
until something else happens.
And one thing that would need
to happen for these cells
to become malignant and to
leave the organ that they were
initially part of is for
there to be a breakdown
in the adhesion between cells.
So for the next
few minutes, I want
to talk about the breakdown
in cell-to-cell adhesion.
So how would a
cancer cell basically
unstick itself
from the cells that
surround it in order to leave
an organ and go somewhere else?
And for that, to explain
that, I have to remind you
about some of the normal biology
of these epithelial cells,
which we talked
about earlier, which
is that they express these
transmembrane proteins
that are adhesion proteins.
So normally, epithelial
cells have adhesion proteins.
And the famous
one for epithelia,
or one of the famous
ones, is called
epithelial or E-cadherin.
And E-cadherin is a
transmembrane protein.
It has an extracellular
domain, but rather
than that extracellular
domain binding
to some secreted ligand,
this extracellular domain
recognizes E-cadherin
molecules on other cells,
and they stick to each other.
And it essentially functions
like cellular Velcro.
So the cells link together, and
they stick to each other such
that they form a
coherent tissue.
So the way that cancer
cells subvert this mechanism
of adhesion is, they
have to do something
that inhibits E-cadherin.
And so cancer cells,
what they can do
is to decrease the
cell-to-cell adhesion,
and I'll tell you
how in just a minute.
And in addition to decreasing
this cell-to-cell adhesion,
they can also promote the genes
that are involved in motility.
So we have to
understand, then, how
it is a cancer cell would
do both of these things.
And I'll start with
cell-to-cell adhesion.
And in contrast to what we've
talked about with the growth
and survival signaling, where
you have mutations that happen
in cancer cells,
and you basically
have an irreversible change
to the genome of the cell,
this change in the adhesive
properties of the cell,
and essentially
their cell state--
because what you see
here, if a cancer cell is
having less adhesion and
getting more migratory,
it's switching from an
epithelial type of state
to a mesenchymal type of state.
And what this is called is
an epithelial-to-mesenchymal
transition, and that
is EMT, for short.
And this EMT is not
a genetic change.
It's not caused by
a genetic change,
but it appears that EMT
results from changes
in gene regulation.
So you can think of it as
more of an epigenetic change,
an epigenetic change
in gene expression.
So there's a change
in gene expression
such that this can
reverse later on.
And there are master
regulators of this process,
which alter gene expression.
And so the type of gene
that alters gene expression,
these are often called
transcription factors.
And there are several
transcription factors
that are master regulators
of this EMT process.
And their names
are Twist, Snail--
another one's called Slug.
There's an Escargot.
You can see this got
a little out of hand.
And you can tell by the
names that they probably
were not discovered in humans.
And in fact, these
genes were discovered
in the same genetic screen
that I outlined before,
where Hedgehog was discovered.
OK.
So it was a genetic
screen in the flies,
and these are genes that affect
the embryonic development
of the fly.
And I'll show you this
view of the fly embryo.
So this is an embryo
here, and you see,
it's an epithelial sheet
surrounding the yolk.
And what happens is, in
early stages of development,
a population of cells
express the Twist gene.
So that's Twist
in the dark here.
And this Twist gene causes
these cells to basically invade
into the middle of the embryo.
So here are the Twist
cells now, going
into the inside of the embryo.
And then these
cells undergo EMT,
and they start to migrate
around inside the embryo.
What this is doing
for the fly is
that these are the
cells that are going on
to form the muscle.
And if you look
at your neighbor,
you might notice that
their muscles are
on the inside of their body.
So this process is basically
putting these cells,
by getting them to move,
it's putting the cells
in the right place
for what they are
going to differentiate into
during embryonic development.
But this process, if
activated during cancer,
can allow these cells to be more
mobile and to leave one organ
and go into another organ.
So cancer isn't inventing
anything new here.
It's corrupting a normal
program that cells have and need
during development, and
it's inactivating it
at an inappropriate time.
So these are all
transcription factors.
And what they do
is, they repress
the expression or
function of cadherin
such that the cells are
no longer as sticky.
So basically, when these
transcription factors
get turned on, it
makes the cells
less sticky to each other.
And it also promotes
their migration.
So it turns on genes that
are important for migration.
This process of EMT, as I
mentioned, is reversible,
and it also involves
interactions between tumor
and stromal cells.
I'll show you an example of--
so in the fly embryo, one thing
that's nice about the flies
is, you can actually
watch this happen live.
And so I'm going to show
you a movie now, showing you
the invasion process.
We're going to have
an embryo here.
And what I'm going
to show you is,
we're looking at the cells that
are expressing Twist and Snail,
and they're on one
side of the embryo.
And I'm going to show you a
section of the embryo that
is analogous to this.
So when the cells
move inside, they're
going to disappear
in this movie.
So when you see the
crease in the embryo,
that's when the
cells are invading
into the middle of the embryo.
And so the cell outlines
are in magenta here.
And what's labeled in green
is a type of motor protein
that's involved in the mobility
of cells and, in this case,
is involved in
these cells moving
into the interior of the embryo.
So here, you see the
motor protein appearing,
and that's when these cells are
going to dive into the embryo.
So it's almost like a waterfall.
These cells are moving into
the inside of the embryo
through this process of
invagination and, subsequently,
EMT.
There it goes again.
You can see the cells
are now on the inside.
So this process of
EMT also involves
interactions between the
cancer cells and the stroma.
And that's illustrated here
because what you can see,
what's being labeled
here, you can
see the nuclei of the
cells, but these cells
at the edge of the tumor are
up-regulating this gene, which
is an alpha-beta integrin, which
I'll mention in just a minute.
And this is getting
up-regulated right where
the tumor contacts the stroma.
And this gene,
alpha-beta integrin,
is a gene that's associated
with motility and EMT.
So on that slide here, one
gene involved in motility
is a class of genes
called integrins.
And so this also results from
the signaling between the tumor
and the surrounding cells.
And again, this is not
something that cancer created.
This is what happens
during wound healing.
So during wound healing,
if you injure yourself,
the wound recruits immune
cells, and the immune cells
signal to the surrounding
skin or epithelial cells
to undergo EMT in order to
close and fill in the wound.
So this is a
natural process that
happens in your body
that is simply getting
corrupted by cancer cells.
All right.
So now let's talk about
this last step of motility.
So this is now how the cells
would break out and move away.
Let's come back to
this movie here.
There are a few things I want
you to notice about this movie.
The first is, holy shit,
that cell is moving.
And so the first aspect of this
is, because the cell is moving,
it suggests that there's some
sort of force being generated.
So the cell is generating force.
And I'm not talking about like
some type of mystical Jedi
force.
I'm talking about the mass
times acceleration force,
so like a physical force, OK?
The second thing I want to
point out about this movie
is that you see that bacterium,
and it's moving around,
this cell is able to
follow that bacterium.
So the cell, in the
force generation process,
is very responsive
to the signals
that that cell is getting.
So the cell is generating
force, and this force
is responsive to signals.
So for the remaining
part of the lecture,
I basically just
want to tell you
about how it is that the cell
generates the force required
to move itself around.
And it involves a
particular type of protein.
It's a component of
the cytoskeleton,
and we've talked
about microtubules
and the microtubule
cytoskeleton and its role
in segregating the chromosome.
But there are other cytoskeletal
systems that the cell has,
and one is called the
actin cytoskeleton, which
is shown on the side above.
And actin, the
actin cytoskeleton,
is a system that is a
biopolymer in the cell.
So this is a biopolymer,
like microtubules.
And actin is a gene.
And the actin gene encodes for
a protein, the actin protein,
and when the actin protein
is made in the cell,
it starts out as being just
a single globular protein.
And when the actin
is in this state,
it is called
globular or G-actin.
But these subunits,
these proteins,
can come together
and form a polymer.
So they can go from being
individual, isolated proteins
to forming a polymer that
forms a long skinny filament.
And this form of the protein
that's forming a biopolymer
is known as
filamentous or F-actin.
And these are long,
skinny filaments.
They can be hundreds
of nanometers,
even microns, in length, so
hundreds of nanometers long.
And the filament width
is about 10 nanometers.
So I'm just trying to give
you a sense of dimensions,
that this is a long, skinny
filament that the cell can
assemble.
And it assembles into these
dense meshworks, which you
can see in the slide up here.
So this is the leading
edge of the cell.
So the cell would be
migrating this way.
And what you see in this cell is
this densely branched network,
and these are all
actin filaments.
So you get this huge dense
forest of actin filaments
that's right at the edge of the
cell that is moving forward.
One thing I want to point out
is, like all things in biology,
this is not a one-way street.
And so these biopolymers
are very dynamic,
meaning they can undergo
assembly and disassembly,
and they can do so on
the timescale of seconds.
One last thing I want to point
out about the actin filament
is, there's a polarity
to the filament such
that there's an end,
known as the plus end,
where growth is
favored, and there's
an end, known as the
minus end, where there's
often de-polymerization.
So you can get a directional
growth of the filament.
So this is where growth happens.
And so in this network
that you're looking at,
the way the actin is oriented--
so I'm going to draw
just a cell here--
you have this dense meshwork
of actin, and in this meshwork,
there's a polarity to the
way the actin filaments are
oriented.
So the cell is
migrating this way,
and the plus ends of
the actin filaments
are facing out right
at the surface.
And the minus ends
are back here.
And so what you have, when
the cell is migrating,
is you have this
biopolymer network that's
growing on this end, but
shrinking on the other end.
And that allows the cell to
generate a constant protrusive
force.
So it's the growth
of actin filaments,
the growth of F-actin, which
generates a protrusive force.
Now if we consider the whole
process of cell migration, what
you can see is that
initially, you're
going to push the
cell membrane forward.
So you get a protrusion.
It pushes it forward.
That's often called a
lamellipodium, or a pseudopod,
and so this part of
the cell moves forward.
But in order for the cell to
have a net motion forward,
it then has to stabilize
that protrusion.
And it stabilizes the protrusion
by adhering to the substrate.
So right now, we're
just considering a cell
moving on a flat substrate.
And so the way it
attaches to the substrate
is through cell matrix adhesion.
And this cell matrix
adhesion is mediated
by another type of adhesion
receptor known as an integrin.
So the cell pushes
forward, anchors itself
on the substrate, pulls its
body along, and then just
repeats that cycle
over and over again.
So the best way I can illustrate
this is, if you think about it,
you get your protrusion.
You get your elbow out.
You put down.
You anchor.
And it's just a
repeated cycle, and it's
able to migrate
across the substrate.
So it's kind of like a
frontal toe mechanism.
You have cycles of protrusion.
You generate
traction, and then you
pull, in order to translocate.
And so that's how cells
are migrating intuitively.
This is just showing you
that cells can pull on stuff.
So not all cells
migrate in this way.
I just wanted to say that.
So 3D cells have
other mechanisms
to migrate that de-emphasize
this traction mechanism
that cells have.
So you can get rid
of all the integrins
that a cell has, and they're
still able to migrate.
And that's because 2D
emphasizes the role of adhesion,
but if you can find the
cell, then the cells
are able to migrate.
So what's shown here are
cells that are not confined.
This is a confined
cell in a micropipette.
And you can see, it's
the same type of cell,
but the cell can
migrate in confinement,
but it can't migrate
outside of confinement.
So in this sense,
the cell is migrating
through a different mode.
And you can think
of it as the cell
is doing some type of
chimney-ing maneuver.
So it's able to get in a
confined environment, push out
against its surroundings,
and that's how the cell then
is able to generate traction
in the absence of an integrin
molecule.
All right.
Great.
So we are set for now.